talk us through what what uh you guys
saw over the weekend yeah well it was
pretty stuck to see isn't it
lick of sewage pollution
impacting one of our most famous beaches
here in Cornwall incidents in Agnes
um you know that's that's that sewage
but a chemical cocktail of sewage
pollution agricultural pollution Urban
runoff and you can see there the really
clear line between that lovely clean
um crisp water and that that plume of
dirty pollution washing out onto the
beach the beach there it's it's quite
Stark and quite shocking isn't it
it is but the Southwest water say that
these kind of
um permitted storm overflows happen uh
because they have to free up space in
their pipes and it's caused by climactic
conditions it's caused by the fact they
say that it was it's been very hot for
such a long time that when we get a lot
of rain it just doesn't percolate into
the the ground as it should and it just
goes into the Overflow system well look
you know sewage pollution is only
supposed to be discharged in exceptional
circumstances that's the law and what
we're seeing more and more is is people
out and about capturing these these
images putting them on social media and
you know the slightest slightest sign of
rain and we just wonder whether that is
exceptional circumstances
um as per the law so you know this is
this is pollution that's damaging our
our health damaging our environment and
it's it's something that you don't
expect to see but yet we're seeing it up
and down the country on our beaches and
in our Rivers all the time what real
risk does it pose to health
she collects um you know sickness
reports through our our safest season
Rivers service our own you know the only
real-time water quality information app
um it's free um and and we're seeing
hundreds of sickness reports submitted
to US every year a stomach upsets ear
nose and throat infections eye
infections some people even being
hospitalized after entering water that's
contaminated
um so it's a real issue with our with
our with our health you know we want to
enjoy these these environments for our
mental health and well-being yet they're
being polluted by all sorts of pollution
let alone you know so agricultural
pollution sewage pollution all kinds of
things that being you know the chemical
cocktail that's entering the environment
but but do you accept that there is
nowhere else for this to go if the Water
Company's pipes and and its reserves are
full what else do you suggest they do
with it well look we
see sort of under investment in our
sewage infrastructure and we need to see
urgent action taken by the water
companies and the government to upgrade
our systems to invest in nature-based
solutions to slow down that water
through the environment planting trees
reinstating Wetlands that kind of thing
and you know the the water industry a
profiteering of this pollution they're
paying billions of pounds out in in
shareholder dividends and millions of
pounds to CEOs in their bonuses their
profiteering of this pollution and we
need to see a decade of ambition to
really tackle this problem of research
pollution
in terms of the pollution on this
particular Beach how long will it be
there for how long will it be out of
bounds to people who want to go out and
enjoy the water well the the discharge
itself has stopped but we um keep our
notification live for for 48 hours after
that pollution incident
um has stopped occurring just to allow
for that dispersal of the water to allow
people to kind of ensure that it's as
safe as possible before and people go in
but ultimately it's people people's own
decision about whether it's safe to go
in the water at that time we we put out
notifications in real time as to where
that surgical pollution is happening and
when
um but it's to allow people to make
those informed decisions about when it's
safe to enter the water and not and
clearly as you're seeing there you know
yesterday it looks pretty pretty
shocking today I've been down to the
beach today it's looking relatively
clean but we still got that pollution
incident live at warning live just so um
we can make sure that that dispersal is
happening and people can make those
informed decisions about what the risks
are
okay Amy slack from service against
sewage good to see you thank you very
much